keegan aiken 25 years old now from alba
michigan
16 strikeouts in 13 and two-thirds he's
only allowed 11 hits
starts things off nicely this evening a
cuny punch down
that's what i love about these young
pitchers dean kramer keegan aiken
not afraid to do this use the inside
part of the plate with your best pitch
your fastball he dots an eye on the
inside corner and gets
ronaldo acuna jr the long-awaited debut
of cole hamills
who's got the ball for the braves this
evening and you see that last year with
the cubs 3.81
143 strikeouts and and a high fastball
he just carved through the orioles
lineup
giving up one hit in his first inning as
a brave it's no score we go to the
second
[Applause]
strike three call keegan aiken with his
third punch out of the night and you
can't argue with the location of it too
four team fastball 95 miles an hour you
see pedro several set up just on the
outside part
exactly where it is delivered it may say
92-93 but it's playing a little bit
better than that because it's spinning
so good
and he drops in a breaking ball and
riley down on strikes
for yet another strikeout his four
strikeout third in a row
but there's gonna be nights and when the
breaking ball is not there the curve
ball you got to go to the cut fast ball
right now keegan nathan's got everything
going strikes out this side of the
second inning
that is the third strikeout in a row on
three pitches
[Applause]
and fifth consecutive strikeout
another strikeout this time against ron
lacuna
well he's got them all going tonight
change-ups
breaking balls the orioles have put the
first two on base in the bottom of the
third
and it turns the lineup card over for
alberto
also excellent against left-handed
pinching
he swings lines this one into left field
hayes gets the send around he'll score
throw goes into second alberto with an
rbi double and they're at second and
third for the orioles
who have got a one-nothing lead well
brandon hyde playing for the big inning
here he lets hansar alberto swing away
and why not the way he wears out
left-handers and he just
laces one so again alberto on its second
velazquez stands at third with nobody
out
3-2 iglesia swings it's a chopper to
swanson he connects to freeman
iglesias out velazquez comes home
two-nothing orioles
now castle hits it out to center
acuna under it makes the catch alberto
tags and he is able to score
so the third has been kind for the
orioles they get three runs
three and two against darno aiken is set
down
eight straight make it
nine off that great play from iglesias
jose iglesias has been really good as of
late
hamill's 6-4 205 wines in the pitch
hit in the air to left field back goes
ozuna he's at the wall he leaps and
makes a catch
marcel took a home run away from nunez
how about that ladies and gentlemen
marcelo zuna d.h
for a week goes out to left field and
makes a great play
what a play timed it perfectly
no doubt it was out of the ballpark and
he brought it back
that's a great catch awesome play
and cole hamill's first outing is over
three in the third innings for cole
hamels
and he gives up three runs on three hits
and yet i'm guessing
all the brains will say after the game
it was a successful return i would think
so too
and there is strikeout number nine for
keegan aiken
that's a new career best and he's gotten
adam duvall
twice just like he's got dansby swanson
twice and this is that change-up boy
starts it right on the outside edge and
a good late action running down and away
from the hot hitting adam duvall
playing the big shift on dansby give him
the whole right side
[Music]
and he just blocked home freddie freeman
how about that
so a gift run for atlanta the orioles
dugout is barking as freddie freeman
trots home with the first atlanta run
on a block by dylan tate and brandon
hyde
wants to know what the youngster did
nunez he got robbed of a home run his
last time up
nunez hits this one fair down the left
field line
iglesias will score easily
severino he gets sent around throw to
the plate
dropped nunez advances to third and the
orioles get a couple more runs
renato nunez with an extra base hit well
they might have robbed him back in the
fourth inning but not this time this
ball is hit equally
as hard by renato nunez the boy gets an
all-speed pitch and just melts it right
over the head of austin riley he gets
all the way down in the corner
cued back to the mound valdez does his
job and the orioles take two out of
three
against the atlanta braves tonight at
camden yards great pitching two big
innings